[Musique]
dans les rues de Londres voici comme
chaque hiver lourd chargé ventru les
marchands de Nyon
pour ce sont les Johnnies personne ne
connaît leur nom Johnny c'est plus
commode et c'est tellement gentil on
sait seulement qu'ils sont breton oui
depuis des siècles la vente des oignons
ici c'est la faire des Bretons
colporteur rémouleur empailleur ont
disparu les Bretons sont restés rieurs
tu es tu es obstiné
[Musique]
rien ne les arrête pas même les
enceintes les plus sacrés comme celle de
Westminster
[Musique]
spécialement pour trismus
[Rires]
mais comme ça fait
longtemps
ils vivent d'ici 9 mois de l'année
fabricant eux-mêmes leur chapelet c'est
leurs affaires et même leurs privilèges
car il ne paye aucune taxe pas plus que
leur père ou leur grand-père non non
payé
[Musique]
[Rires]
43 ans
ça devait être dur
ça
vous a pas plu vous avez passé
on peut commencer on peut finir pour ton
vœu c'est surtout ça qui vous plaît
c'est ça ça c'est la liberté
[Rires]
ça vous intéresse beaucoup aussi
un peu de sympathie chez les Anglais
pour les Bretons question oui on a
beaucoup
je crois que je sais pas mais
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça réchauffe le cœur